au programme de cette semaine un choc
des générations sur france 2 à venir en
terre inconnue est le témoignage
exclusif de la femme de romain grosjean
après son accident c'est parti pour
notre bloc-notes et on commence avec les
enfants de la télé dans son dernier
numéro plusieurs invités de toutes les
générations étaient sur le plateau du
côté des anciens on retrouvait laurent
ruquier jean luc lemoine et le magicien
eric antoine de l'autre la jeune
chanteuse webzen et forcément quand on
parle vieille musique ça coince salvador
henri salvador
on passe d'un voyage dans le temps un
voyage sur la planète avec le chanteur
amir en effet l'artiste a dévoilé sur le
vouloir il allait effectivement
participer prochainement à l'émission
rendez vous en terre inconnue ont dit à
venir que vous revenez tout juste du
tournage de rendez vous en terre
inconnue l'émission de france 2
j'aimerais en parler
donc la réponse est oui un lapsus qui
lui a échappé en direct sur rtl et qui
confirme la rumeur et on termine avec
marion jollès la femme de romain
grosjean qui a décidé de témoigner de la
peur qu'elle a vécue lors de l'accident
de voiture son mari le 29 novembre lors
du grand prix de bahreïn
elle explique avoir cru perdre son mari
elle se trouvait alors devant sa télé à
des milliers de kilomètres de là chez ou
presque était 9h30 4
le coureur automobile sentira finalement
avec des blessures superficielles et on
referme ce bloc notes pour cette semaine
alors rendez vous vendredi prochain pour
en écrire un autre et la basse
évidemment romain grosjean c'est vrai la
passe de seconde de sa femme en fait pas
moins horrible l'effroyable s'est bien
terminée alors une question quand même
parce que la bourde labour m2 à venir
jeter mais ce n'est pas en direct
pourquoi prix ne coupe pas ça aucun
intérêt pour rtl de couper cette
séquence a été repris par tous et et
voilà donc c'est normal qu'il laisse moi
je trouve que c'est une très très bonne
idée les faits n'avance laventure bande
son avec christine bravo ça a été génial
c'est un garçon qui est adorable et
réseaux sociaux avait adoré très
positifs et tout est le lait des scores
étaient pas mal pratiquement trois mille
ans mois d'août ça c'est comment les
scores c'est un petit peu en berne
depuis que j'ai repris par an
en berne lambert c'est un jeune qui
présente il était en place et bien
entendu par frédéric lopez on n'est pas
réglé il n'a jamais présenté
présenté il pas qu'il en faut un numéro
de terrain connu à dubaï ne s'inscrit
dans le président de l'émission à savoir
des invités comme vianney qu'il a déjà
enregistré là où el madani ou encore ou
encore quand gastambide